hey what's up guys I know in my last
video I asked whether or not you wanted
to see the crossbow dowel shooter the
super spoon or the regular catapult and
it seems due to votes that you guys
really wanted to see the crossbow Dallas
shooter 298 votes to zombies 910 also
one of my viewers put a poll up and it
was apparent that twelve hundred and
sixty-three people wanted to see the
crossbow dowel shooter yes so that was
basically like 80% of everyone before I
start I need to give a really big thanks
to South Shore dental arch which is my
brother and sister-in-laws office and
they fixed my front teeth as you could
see from these pictures I had bonding
done about twelve years ago and it
started to discolor and make my teeth
with really bad they decided to do six
veneers on my front teeth from canine to
canine not only are my teeth whiter but
I also have the confidence that I need
to smile and show off my pearly whites
you can check them out at facebook.com
slash South Shore DDS or at south shore
DDS comm thanks guys the crossbow looks
something like this
and it uses ammunition like these dowels
to basically go inside you push back and
you grab the tip of the dowel hold it
pull back you are never going to point
this at anyone however one thing you can
also shoot in the crossbow is are these
skewers so if I put a skewer in here and
aim it at something like hello to make
the crossbow dowel shooter we're going
to need a pen with a round body just
like this you don't want to use a pen
that has those ridges like this one so
you need one with a round body you're
also going to need a piece of printer
paper eight-and-a-half by eleven should
work just fine you're also going to need
a set of dowels these dowels I got from
Michaels they are three
sixteenth of an inch and they come with
15 you're also going to need some
pencils some rubber bands about seven
rubber bands I got these rubber bands at
Target in a case of about 600 and you're
also going to need some masking tape
which I happen to get at Staples right
so let's take four pencils out in total
and we're going to take two of them and
basically we're going to grab one of the
rubber bands and we're going to leave
about an inch to an inch and a half from
the end to where we put the rubber band
and you're just going to take the rubber
band wrap it around twist it put it
around twist it put it around I'm
assuming most of you guys know how to do
this so basically just twist it and wrap
it around like that until you get
basically till the end until it gets
really tight right about there should be
good okay we're going to do this to the
other end take another rubber band about
an inch and a half away from the end
we're going to deal with another set of
pencils so just like before take a
rubber band and just wrap it around flip
it around and do the same here
all right and there you go now try to
make sure that these pencils are edge to
edge because these pencils do have
ridges on them so now you should have
two sets of pencils that are wrapped
with rubber bands all right so you're
going to take one of the pencil pairs
and you're going to put it on top of the
other pencil pair it doesn't matter
which orientation or way it's facing and
you're going to move it up to about a
third the length of the pencils so right
about there
then you're going to take another rubber
band and you're going to put it around
this pair and this pair and then you're
going to once again twist on the other
side and wrap it once again around this
end and this end so that you basically
are wrapping in this direction now I'm
going to take the rubber band and twist
it and put it around this end and this
end to effectively get a wrap going the
other way as well so about three wraps
and each direction should be good I just
wanted to mention if it's easier for you
to use two different sets of rubber
bands to wrap one just around this way
and then the other one just around that
way you could do that as well or you can
even use tape to get these two to stay
like this to make the barrel what you're
going to do is to obviously take the cap
off of the depende that we have here
okay we're going to take the piece of
paper and we're going to lay the pen
down on the very end here we're then
going to grab the end of the paper and
we're going to wrap it pretty tightly
almost as tight as you can get it
and then you're going to wrap it down
making sure that it's rolling on the
ends - so you want to keep going around
and wrapping all the way up all the way
up until you get to the very end and you
should have something like this okay now
you're gonna have to practice this
because as you'll see it may not be as
tight in certain areas it's really not
that big of a deal you're then going to
take some masking tape out of the width
of the paper okay and you're going to
attach it to the end of the paper that's
been rolled up okay so I'm attaching it
to the end of the paper that hasn't
quite been folded down yet alright just
like that and as you'll see I have some
excess here and I'm going to rip it
right there now I'm going to take the
rest of the paper and I'm just going to
keep on folding it so that that piece of
tape would just stuck to my finger here
basically lays down on the rest of the
paper and seals it nice and closed now
we have to get the pen out so to do that
all you need to do is to just take
another pen or pencil stick it in the
end and you'll see the pen will come out
and that is how you make the barrel of
the crossbow we're almost done we just
need to attach the barrel and then
attach the two rubber bands and make an
ammunition pouch take the rest of the
crossbow and hold it like this so that
the two pencils which we placed across
the other two are on top like that we're
going to hold the barrel and line it up
with the end or the bottom of these two
pencils like that
we're going to make sure it aligns with
the rest of the bottom pencils then take
a piece of masking tape about six inches
long and you're going to take it attach
it right there and then just basically
wrap it around the barrel and the
pencils it doesn't matter if it's not
neat it just needs to basically give it
support then we're going to do this two
more times
take another piece about six inches long
attach it right here and then just wrap
it around just like that all right and
for the last one just attach it here and
you don't want to pull down on this okay
so just basically let this fall down
here and don't type don't basically
tighten it so just basically hold it
here and then just wrap it around just
like that all right so now that we have
the barrel secured we're going to attach
the two rubber bands to do that we're
going to take it and you're going to
have to really pull apart on these a
little bit because they're very tight
due to the rubber band so if you can
kind of squeeze that in there pull this
apart and see if you can squeeze that
down there you might have to loosen the
rubber bands but if you want to get it
down to right about there at the base of
the metal piece that holds the eraser
the other side let's try squeeze it
apart up and I got it in and you want to
squeeze it all the way down as far as
you can really just like that if you're
not able to open this like I said you
have to either loosen on this or you can
take the edge of a a clothespin and
wedge it in here like that and open them
or you can also use a flathead
screwdriver okay so at this point now
I have these two rubber bands what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get some
tape and I'm going to first take the
tape and wrap it under the right rubber
band and kind of fold it like that at
the very edge you want this to be at the
very edge of the rubber band when you
pull on it you're going to do the same
with the other rubber band but you don't
want the edges of the rubber band
exactly next to one another you want to
leave you want to leave about an inch
and a half like that so you see how I
kind of trapped it there and now I'm
going to fold it there you go so now you
see there's one rubber band there's the
other one and then I'm going to take
this go inside again and wrap it around
so now I have created the ammunition
pouch and now I'm just going to
strengthen it up a little bit so just
take a little bit of extra extra tape
and I'm going to wrap it around this way
now put it on front wrap it around
behind come around front again and that
is your ammunition pouch okay
and that right there is the crossbow so
now I'll show you how you can shoot it
the best way to do this is to have the
ammunition pouch already at the base
here then what you can do is you take
the dowel and you hold it like this and
when it gets to the end you'll see it
will start pushing on the ammunition
pouch what you do then is you can pinch
the ammunition pouch hold it like this
below the barrel you can even put your
tip of your finger here okay so you want
to hold it like this
you pull back and you can kind of aim it
like that just try that again push it in
push the ammunition pouch down pull back
and there you go
so again just set up the ammunition
pouch there and it'll be a little bit
easier for you to shoot alright guys
thanks so much for watching my video on
how to make the crossbow dowel shooter
if you did enjoy it please give it a
thumbs up or a like down below and also
subscribe by clicking the subscribe
button I think it's down below now and
it might be in red if you're not
subscribed so click that if you want to
see more also let me know what you want
to see next leave a comment in the
comment section below I have some magic
tricks that I can show maybe some easy
levitations you know say you take a card
like this and you want to levitate it
all you need to do is to really give it
a good spin you really got to make sure
that you have enough control over it
just like that
alright guys thanks so much for watching
and I'll see you next time